hablemos sobre un concepto que
probablemente confunde a muchos de
ustedes estudiantes de química pero en
realidad es un concepto muy simple el
mol no no se refiere a los moluscos ni
al mole que comemos en química es algo
muy diferente el mol en química es un
número y ese número es 6.0 2 por 10 a la
este número parece muy grande y también
se le conoce como el número de abogado
número
de abogado
y es todo lo que tienen que saber que el
mol es solamente un número existen
muchas otras definiciones rebuscadas
como por ejemplo esta definición es una
traducción del sitio wikipedia en inglés
y pueden ver que está muy largo dice el
mol se define como la cantidad de
sustancia en un sistema que contiene
tantas entidades elementales como átomos
hay en 12 gramos de carbono 12 yo les he
dicho que el mol es 6.0 2 por 10 a la 23
y en esta parte dice como átomos hay en
12 gramos de carbono 12 eso significa lo
voy a anotar aquí abajito
eso significa
un molde carbono de carbono 12
en
12 gramos
de carbono que más nos está diciendo
esto aquí nos dice que es la cantidad de
sustancia refiriéndose a la de cualquier
molécula se puede convertir esto a
gramos
esta definición está muy confusa es más
simple entenderlo así el mol es una
forma de pasar de gramos a unidades de
masa atómica o viceversa
recuerden cuál es la masa atómica del
carbono 12 12 por eso se le llama
carbono 12 y no 14 entonces si su masa
es 12 unidades de masa atómica y tenemos
un molde esto es decir 6.0 2 por 10 a la
23 átomos todos esos átomos conforman
una masa de 12 gramos otra manera de
entenderlo es un gramo
un gramo es igual a un mod
de unidades de masa atómica o lo pueden
escribir como un gramo
es igual a 6.02 por 10 a la 23 unidades
de masa atómica uma y esto nos sirve
porque en parte es para entenderlo mejor
que lo que entendemos de la definición
de wikipedia pero sobre todo porque nos
ayuda a pasar del mundo atómico ya sea
que estemos usando unidades de masa
atómica o cualquier otra cosa
relacionada con átomos lo podemos
traducir a nuestro mundo en donde es más
común usar gramos un gramo es una
cantidad muy pequeñita de masa
imagínense 1000 gramos hacen un
kilogramo un kilogramo es de
aproximadamente 2.2 libras etcétera pero
lo que quiero decir es que un gramo es
muy poquito aquí hay una tonelada de
átomos en una cantidad muy pequeña de la
masa en que nosotros medimos las cosas
esto significa que en 12 gramos de
carbono
tenemos una tonelada de átomos
6.0 2 por 10 a la 23 este es un número
muy grande incluso difícil de imaginar
alguna vez me lo explicarán con el
diámetro de un cabello
este es el cabello y en el diámetro hay
un millón de carbonos un millón de
átomos de carbono otro ejemplo es que si
ustedes tienen una manzana voy a dibujar
mi manzanita una manzana
y quisieran tomar uno de sus átomos
cualquiera de los que la conforman y
hacerlo tan grande como la manzana
entonces la manzana sería del tamaño de
nuestro planeta tierra aún es un poco
difícil de entender la cantidad de cosas
que hay desde tamaño pero digamos que
tenemos un gramo de hidrógeno un gramo
de hidrógeno si tenemos un gramo de
hidrógeno eso significa que tenemos un
mod
de hidrógeno y como lo sé bueno porque
la masa del hidrógeno es 1 así que en
general para cualquier elemento por
ejemplo cuál es la masa de tomaré un
molde aluminio
un móvil
de aluminio he tomado 6.0 2 por 10 a la
23 átomos de aluminio cual es la masa de
esa cantidad de átomos bueno cada uno de
ellos tiene un número atómico de 13
verdad pero si tomamos la masa atómica
en este caso es de 26 98 dejémoslo en 27
aluminio 27 y tenemos un molde esto
entonces la masa es de 27 gramos
entonces si tenemos un molde el átomo su
masa molecular se traduce directamente
como el número de gramos
ahora quiero saber un mol de jr un amor
de hierro
56 verdad
digamos que estamos trabajando con el
isótopo de hierro 56 entonces si tengo
un molde ese átomo esto tiene una masa
atómica de 56 gramos de 56 gramos
esto es 56 unidades atómicas por átomo y
tenemos un molde eso es decir 6.0 2 por
10 a la 23 x 56 unidades de masa atómica
y si lo dividimos entre unidades de masa
atómica por gramos
nos quedan 56 gramos lo importante aquí
es que al tomar cualquier número de masa
atómica que nos corresponda por ejemplo
si tienen silicio un molde silicio tiene
una masa de 28 gramos que me dicen de
dos moles de silicio
molex
de silicio su masa atómica es 28 silicio
bueno si un molde silicio es igual a 28
gramos
entonces dos moles es igual a 56 gramos
y si les dijera que tenemos 4 moles de
oxígeno
cuatro moles de oxígeno cuya masa
atómica es de 16 cual es la masa de esta
gigantesca cantidad de átomos bueno si
un molde oxígeno tiene 16 gramos
entonces 4 moles por 16 es igual a 64
gramos 64 gramos quizás los confundo un
poco porque estoy usando los moles como
un número pero es la manera más fácil de
entenderlo ya que nos traslada del
número de masa atómica a gramos y en
esos gramos hay 6.0 2 por 10 a la 23
átomos por ejemplo de 12 gramos de
carbón eso es todo lo que hay que saber
sobre el mol es sólo un número
los invito a seguir jugando con lo que
hemos estado haciendo es súper
importante tener bien claro el manejo de
los moles para que no se confundan
después cuando empecemos a ver otros
conceptos
la energía en términos de kilo y un
sobre mol buscar cuál es la energía de
tal o cual reacción y ese tipo de cosas
realmente traten de hacer más ejercicios
para que puedan comprender esto lo más
que pueda y háganos saber si no pueden
para hacer otro vídeo sobre esto porque
es muy importante que lo entiendan